let's bring in Tony Boselli one of the
great offensive linemen in history
played for the Jags and now works for
Westwood one he was on the sidelines
last night on the call for the broadcast
if the Chargers in Chiefs played ten
times who wins will I think I think that
she's win six of the ten thank you very
close I think the Chiefs are a little
bit better just because of the offenses
you know with fashionable homes what are
they able to do offensively big play
wise easier for them you can see that
last night even watching the game that
just seemed easier throughout the game
but one thing the Chargers have died
think very few teams do is they have a
perseverance and the toughness about
them that they hang in there I mean
think fact that Pittsburgh game just a
few weeks ago they were down by two
scores in that game as well came back on
the road they're really impressive yeah
I thought when they're down 14 that it
could get ugly and then we saw a
different charger team and we saw that
in Pittsburgh the old Chargers don't win
these games on the road Tony so what is
the difference you know I think it's I
give Anthony with a ton of credit I just
like to make up this team and how they
approach it they make really good
adjustments on both offense and defense
about Gus Bradley did a great job last
night with a defensive plan just hanging
in there they played extremely hard they
tackle all on defense and then
offensively when you got Philip Rivers I
mean the guy seen everything I mean he's
been through everything so I don't think
there's much it's gonna faze him and you
can see that there's just a resiliency
of the entire group
the Chargers going for two now in the
moment I know what obviously I found out
the end result and they they're
successful but in the moment I went I
get it going for the win on the road but
I wouldn't have gone for two in that
situation what did you think of that
decision in the moment you know you
could argue the way I'm not sure I had
the guts to do it if you step back and
look at it on the road with Kenzie's
offense the way that how explosive they
are and he was there a thing that I can
think about the Chargers are really in a
low risk situation because they already
have the number five five playoff seed
wrapped up I mean no one's catching them
for that top wild-card spot and if they
win
they're still not guaranteed the
division because they need help with
Kenzi losing one more and so I think a
meal in sitting there were on the road
one point against explosive offense
we've just played the best ten minutes
of football we've had this entire game
and if we win great we're on the roads a
big wind to lift this team up
if we don't it's not going to change our
playoff position one bit and I really do
think you're getting to overtime you
lose that coin flip you might never get
the ball back he's one of the great
offensive linemen in NFL history Tony
Boselli the lead analyst for Thursday
Night Football in Westwood One joining
us from the plane are you in coach no no
thankfully uh Howie dinner often
Westwood one in my contract I thought I
wouldn't be talking to you right now
because I'll be screaming at people are
people enjoying your analysis who are
sitting around you on the plane I was
watching game tapes a guy comes up
because what do you do for a living with
my sides I get on the plane with people
hoping I don't sit next to them the best
team in the AMC right now is I'm still
gonna say the Chiefs even though I don't
think anyone wants to play the charges
in a tough playoff game the one thing I
worry about the Chiefs is they really
are a dome team that's what it feels
like their offense what happens if they
get home playoff games in Kansas City
and you have a snowy wet windy game
because they're not a great defensive
team and so I don't think they're going
to hold up over 60 minutes defensively
will they be able to score points in to
add water
also with mahomes he's doing things that
you just
he makes them seem a little more normal
or routine but they're not and you have
played with great quarterbacks being an
offensive lineman how do you assess what
you see with mahomes when he's under
duress it's his arm strength is what
allows them to do things that are
uncanny and what it does to a defense it
makes it forces you discoveries more of
the field because where a guy scrambling
you know you might have 50 yards
of depth to cover at the defense you
better extend that 15 yards of Koch
Oklahoma because there's no you know
there's no telling where he's gonna
throw it and not only that he could be
rolling to his right we saw it last
night
you know the cardinal rules don't throw
back over the middle of the field
well he doesn't consistently and he has
such arm strength he can throw across
his body on a line and the ball can get
there which I don't know I've never seen
a guy try it like he does and I'm not
sure many guys in history this league
I've had the arm strength attach contest
is it mandatory if you're an offensive
lineman you can't wear sleeves in cold
weather yes yes there's actually rule
read needed that as you as you get
baptized as an offensive lineman you
know as early as high school and you
know you go through a class and a one is
no sleeves in cold weather
can you fit in the airplane bathroom
it's very difficult you know it's some
of these bathrooms nowadays refuse have
to open up I have to go in sideways
and shut it and as I do like almost a
180 to get in front of it with my head
to the side I'm telling you what always
worried analyze some of these bathrooms
I go what if I have to go number two I
don't think I could shut the door on the
toilet very uncomfortable feeling well
that'll do it pretty much exhausted
everything we need to talk about there
Tony great to talk to you safe travels
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]